hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
tsum einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich jedes gut das ist
jetzt wieder ein bisschen dumm gelaufen
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen ich hab euch
vor ungefähr einer woche dauern gewinnen
einer umfrage teilzunehmen da geht es
nämlich darum was soll ich als nächstes
bestellen entweder für 3000 da wirklich
ich schwöre ich wäre dazu bereit gewesen
mit 3400 euro bei saturn einzukaufen ein
paket zu bestellen lassen wollte ich
gerne eure meinung wissen ob ich nicht
vielleicht erst mal 10.000 euro noch bei
mediamarkt stellen soll
und natürlich waren die meisten halt für
die 3400 europa touren
das problem ist am nächsten tag war
einfach dieses angebot weg das gibt es
nicht mehr ich habe sogar eine make für
diesen saturn in europa das so man
irgendwie isenburg oder so habe ich ihn
geschrieben ob man da vielleicht noch
etwas machen kann bis heute keine
antwort deswegen hoffe ich da kommt
wieder was neues wenn ich an sich auch
ganz optimistisch aber ja deswegen habe
ich jetzt halt dann dass media markt
paket bestellt für 1000 euro
was ja auch schon mal eine menge geld
ist und ich bin mal gespannt weil ich
muss sagen wir hatten bis jetzt auf
jeden fall zwei pakete von media markt
die waren wirklich überhaupt nicht gut
es war doch nur 100 und zwar nach eurem
meine ich deswegen hoffe ich einfach mal
dass meine 1000 euro hiermit besser
investiert sind und sie nicht wenn ich
das ausgepackt habe so viel wechseln
weil es wäre wirklich es wird sehr sehr
bitter für mich wenn dann nur scheiße
drin ist die man nicht weiter verkaufen
aber sonst war es wir werden sehen leute
ihr seht schon ich war zu neugierig ich
habe leicht rein geschaut weil das
papier stand jetzt schon drei tagen ich
musste einfach mal kurz einmal
reingucken da habe ich auch aufgenommen
hey leute ich kann einfach viel zu
neugierig man ich muss einmal reingucken
das geht jetzt schon zwei tage rum bevor
ich das richtige video mache ist
ziemlich übel einmal nur ganz kurz
einmal gucken nur gucken fritz gemacht
dass er gute sachen drin sind
gibt's nicht mehr 2000 euro aus aber ich
weiß es nicht ich weiß es nicht wir
startet einfach mal rein es läuft wie
immer ich bleibe richtig weiß ein
und dann schauen wir mal an sich ist ein
wert versprochen einen mindestwert von
2000 euro ob wir das erreichen ich mag
es zu bezweifeln aber letzte häufiger es
wird spannend als erstes haben wir ein
ziel gate mall 3.5 interne 34 10
terabyte festplatte 14 härteste menge
ich gehe auf jeden fall davon aus die
kostet über 150 euro
wo steht eigentlich vielleicht sogar
mehr kein plan
ihr werdet schon sehen ich werde erst am
ende sehen also das ist noch mal ganz
gut ich das jetzt einfach nur so rinnen
machen wir weiter
nächstes produkt als nächstes haben wir
hier eine easy power power längst inhalt
bisschen ein bisschen weg die wirklich
keinen großen wert mehr haben
ich würde aber trotzdem mal sagen 20
euro bekommen weil vielleicht weil die
macht mir schon hochwertigen eindruck
weiter geht ist das ein buch oder als
junger da hab ich ja klasse
danke für dieses wunderbare buch ihr
seht schon leute 35 eur 99 hat es mal
gekostet jetzt kostet es noch 5 und
selbst für fünf euro hat es niemand
gekauft die welt von tom clancy's ghost
recon nie gehört ich weiß noch nicht
warum hier ein gut drin ist so hier
haben wir kopfhörer sony mdr
die sind glaube ich schon ein bisschen
älter die sind bestimmt schon mindestens
fünf jahre auf marc trotzdem denke ich
dass sie vielleicht auch noch ein wert
von 50 euro haben
auch hier ist der wert 1 wird das sieht
gut aus und homo decke 1 1 handy ein zte
texten ich muss sagen sieht eigentlich
ziemlich hochwertig aus soll ich mal
aufmachen vielleicht kann man es
wirklich einmal aufnahmen auch wenn es
dann natürlich ein bisschen an wert
verliert ich glaube da ist ein computer
ich stelle es erst mal zur seite
vielleicht weil enke vor
ich denke aber das hat einen guten wert
ich bin nicht so deutlich euro ich sehe
halt das ding hat im 1 128 arbeit
stellte das mal dahin vielleicht weiß
keiner auf danach will weiter mit diesem
flop hier den ich sie mag an die macht
auch anscheinend allen möglichen rahmen
vorbei die ja vermutlich auch coole
sachen machen nur in einem paket landen
dann natürlich nur sachen die jetzt
nicht mehr den größten wert haben wie
diese kopfhörer ich sehe aber da ist
noch einiges möglich dass die box nach
unten auf dem boden die haben wir noch
200.000 natürlich von gc
das tut mir leid weil ich kriege jetzt
bestimmt wieder ärger aber ich nicht
weiß wie es ausgeht vielleicht heißt
hier auf 13 das glaube ich jetzt nicht
oder
wir haben wirklich wieder eine packung
mit packung kaffee da drin leute wer
erinnert sich noch an mein erstes saturn
unboxing 200 euro saturn blog daran zwei
von diesen kaffeedosen drin warum auch
immer aber das werde ich auf jeden fall
behalten weil ich habe gerade noch dran
gedacht scheiße du musst auf dem rückweg
noch beim supermarkt vorbei fahren und
ihr eine neue packung kaffee bohnen
kaufen meine kaffeemaschine ist nämlich
leer
deswegen oder das kann ich mir jetzt
sparen okay hier haben wir ein kabel für
einen hersteller hat endlich auch ein
wert oder das lohnt sich halt auch gar
nicht weiter zu verkaufen weil der
aufwand viel größer ist als das geld was
man dann eigentlich dafür bekommen die
fahrer in hamburg
hier haben wir ein net 4 m 1 router der
sieg auf jeden fall ziemlich neu aus
also so als wäre das produkt noch nicht
lange auf mark und ich glaube auch dass
der neidvoll
1 über 200 euro kostet jeweils hier
schon sehen ich werde gleich ist alle
preise zusammenrechnen
ich denke aber wir sind hier noch längst
nicht annähernd 1000 euro und eigentlich
müssen wir 2000 euro voll machen
deswegen kriege ich schon ein bisschen
wagner kopf hoch wir haben noch ein paar
sachen ich mache einfach mal mit mit
dieser sache weiter
das ist nämlich ein ich denke mal hier
haben wir jetzt das teuerste produkt in
diesem paket das ist ein medion es 22 00
3 mini pc den musste ich jetzt auf jeden
fall mal auflaufen weil ich würde ihnen
wieder aussieht und das ist ja auch für
euch interessant das ist wirklich ein
sehr kleines ding ich hatte noch nie so
einen kleinen pc einer hand das ist
kassen wenn man sich so daran gedacht
wie groß früher mal computer waren mein
erster pc der war gefühlt so groß wieder
rauchen und jetzt kann man so eine
leistung auch schon so schön klein
kompakt im sonnencreme pc bekommen dass
er auf jeden fall weiß und ich glaube
auch dass das teil mindestens 200 euro
kostet und das war auf jeden fall
richtig weiter geht's ich glaube ich
habe noch ein weiteres handy gesehen
ich habe immer das mal aus ihr haben wir
von extern ein fast start okay du kannst
du ein handy auflegen und das wird
schnell auf weiter geht's mit dem sony
c310 sind ein kopfhörer um sport zu
machen können nicht runterfallen dass
ein bändchen weil auch nicht schlecht
denke ich mal die hamborner wert von 30
euro auf wie verrückt genau dieses handy
habe ich meinem opa letztens gegeben das
ist von joachim nation ewig ist kann man
ja so sagen dass sensoren einließ oder
mit großen tasten ok big band im
mauerwerk brauchen also im an die lieber
60 dem ok das bisschen ein an den über
80-jährigen von euch halt meine
kommentare die halt jetzt eins also ob
es wirklich leute gibt die über 80 sind
ja ich wundere mich immer wieder welche
altersgruppe sich auch gerne mal meinen
content anschaut das ist echt sehr heiß
also wenn über 80 sind schreibt mir noch
super gehrmann kommen
da würde ich mich sehr freuen und wenn
da wirklich jemand dabei ist er jetzt
nicht okay das ist ein bisschen
schwierig ich hatte uns gesagt dann
schenke ich dem das dann hat er eine
müll in den kommentaren dass sie 85
weiter geht's mit der und die sind gut
sondern sind zwei dass dinge das sieht
man oft in freibädern und so sie ist
sogar wasserdicht wäre ich eine youtube
box und hier aber noch hamburger
pressekammer die haben wir einen amazon
ecke wo beides ist das ist allerdings
eben was fürs auto und das hier ist
jetzt der west hier haben wir noch eine
praktische handy halte nun kann ich
selber eigentlich ganz gut gebrauchen
hier haben wir noch 120 gigabyte gegen
diesen speicher muss ich gleich mal
google
ihr habt den preis schon erfahren dann
hier noch eine kleine musikbox entgehen
kann sich auf jeden fall eine gute marke
dann hier noch meine bank die haben wir
noch zwei tüchern
draußen machen noch irgendwas zum
speicher einen adapter und hier eine ein
handy case für ein iphone xs max von der
marke bugatti stabil
ja ja ich weiß auch nicht also ich kann
absolut ich glaube das ist nicht das ist
auf jeden fall nicht mehr als 1300 euro
was ich hier liegen habe denke ich mal
also es würde mich extrem überraschend
ich muss das jetzt mal zusammenrechnen
und wir sehen wir uns gleich wieder ihr
habt auf jeden fall schon ungefähres
gefühl wo es hingeht preislich ich nehme
mein gott wtf 574 euro 99 kostet das
ding ich werde reich ich dachte okay 200
euro kriegt dafür wohl okay ein bisschen
runter gesetzt ist es hier kostet nur
noch 400 euro aber trotzdem trotzdem gut
das ist auf jeden fall nicht schlecht
ich glaube wir kommen doch auf die 2k
okay ich bin so gespannt jetzt jetzt
kommt der moment ich rechne jetzt
zusammen und ich finde dass jetzt immer
einfach auf zehner beträge auf oder halt
so ungefähr oder nein dachte ja ich war
lange nicht mehr in der schule 34 euro +
ich muss sagen ich bin zufrieden dass
man das ist auf jeden fall bis jetzt das
beste paket wir haben einfach einen
gesamtwert von 1.700 einem euro das
hätte ich überhaupt niemals gedacht ich
muss doch paar prozent gegeben aber ich
denke dass ich aus der sache schon sie
locker mit 500 euro plus rausgehen
was das ganze jetzt noch keiner machen
würde wäre wenn dieses produkt 5 geht
fähig ist dann kostet sie mich noch mal
200 euro mehr
ich glaube nicht das wird ja eigentlich
auch vorne auf der verpackung
draufstehen aber ich würde es mal kurz
auf machen weil dann kann ich sagen das
wäre so geil alter dann hätte ich
wirklich 2000
du bist glauben ich leider nicht schade
also soweit zum wert von 230 euro sonst
hätte irgendwie 450 gekostet oder so wie
heute
das lief doch echt mal ganz gut ich
wollte noch kurz sagen alle sachen gibt
es jetzt wieder auf einem stück lucky
loonie punkt de schenkt das gerne ab
alex wie es noch mal ein kleiner
gutscheincode könnt ihr dann einlösen
und noch ein bisschen rabatt abstauben
ich habe ja ein vorletztes video gesagt
dass irgend jemand der ein kommentar
schreibt dieses iphone bekommt das ding
ist sich idiot hat mal wieder vergessen
dass ihr euren in sanaa zu schreiben ist
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich poste
dass jetzt gleich in meiner instagram
story und der erste darauf antwortet
kriegt es einfach und als entschuldigung
bekommt der zweite der office sowie
antwortet dieses ding und der dritte ein
geiles paket von mir also wo ich noch
ein paar sachen die ich hier noch
überhaupt macht das gerne und dann habe
ich die sachen auch lustig post das dann
auch direkt danach also es wird direkt
aufgelöst und dank fürs zuschauer leute
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen schreibt
gerne in die kommentare was ich noch zu
bestellen soll
und wir sind uns dann am sonntag wieder
ganz neues video aber jetzt sehr gerne
kanalbau 32